immanuel kant is considered to be the most important
philosopher of all times he actually
made two great discoveries in the eighteenth century
that
still keep us in suspense to this day
on the one hand he founded the globally
valid categorical imperative on the
other hand he was the first
philosopher ever to answer the age-old
human question as in
our brain gains knowledge
in his main work, the critique of
pure reason, he
examined the functioning of the
human thinking apparatus on over 1000 pages. he
asked the critical question: what can people actually
recognize with their thinking with certainty and what not
about it? he worked like a man obsessed
after eleven years he gave
his answer to mankind and it had recognized it in itself
our reason is only able
to recognize with certainty what
we previously
saw, heard, tasted
and smelled with our five senses and therefore one can,
for example, god w  neither recognize nor
prove
therefore has no body and no
intuition kant gave the researchers
for the first time a sensationally simple and
perfect logical set of
instruments that is still valid today
and makes all results
comparable worldwide because every theory, no matter how
good it may be, always has to be that way
kant be provable by observations, for example
by repeatable, visible
experiments
in his second major work the critique
of practical reason he made the
equally immodest attempt
to answer once and for all the question of how people
should act best
there is also a standard for ethically
correct
action  in the end he had a
spectacular answer that has caused a stir to this day
and the book knew in
60 minutes explains
these two main works by
immanuel kant to you in a lively way using
more than 80 central quotations and i
think it was a really big discovery
for  U.N  enormous importance for today's
personal life as well as for
society